ja ich bin eigentlich ja schon längst am start und nämlich gerade mal gucken was für
emotes besonders beliebt sind hier auf frankfurt faces z die musik kann sich auch nicht entscheiden
ob lauter leise aber schon alles wir haben jetzt übrigens wir haben jetzt übrigens als
im auto noch 0 0 w haben wir noch die geht endlich scroll von kathos irgendwie nächste
bei was ich unbedingt bräuchte brauchen wir den da moment das andere das andere war auch
ganz cool wartet mal wo war es denn jetzt eben und das ist das ist auch so eine kacke
an endlich scroll dass es immer wieder an der gleichen stelle anfängt monka speed für die
arbeit schlecht aber dennoch okay da muss ich gleich noch mal im channel hinzufügen aber erst
mal hier muss ich was meinem board hinzufügen white people also immer
das sieht das sieht schon ziemlich kacke aus weil man das so groß zieht oder wie viele emotes gibt
es denn bei ffz ich glaube 25 und mit abo 40 irgendwie sowas log in to add emotes ich bin
auch schon logged in feels wired man ja wired champ ach jetzt jetzt sagt jetzt hat er auf einmal gecheckt dass ich logged in bin oh megalol
so jetzt haben wir auch noch white people happy im channel zur verfügung da hatte die welt drauf
gewartet den rest war danach ja so leute also was wir heute vorhaben es wird ein bisschen abenteuerlich
ich habe das ja schon mal gemacht aber ich habe gesehen es gibt eine neue version von meiner staubsauger
firma das heißt und die haben richtig viele gute änderungen drin zum beispiel wir können mal das change log angucken
ja das braucht ein paar minuten es braucht fünf minuten ich muss mal kurz mal eine vorschau hier richtig aufmachen
recent events was hat mich eigentlich gerissen warum habe ich eigentlich tippis stream genommen
für donations und streamlabs für alles andere kann mir das irgendjemand erklären phoenix danke
für den sub der matt k ist auch am start twitch prime nice also das war's für heute das war's für heute
können wir uns mal kurz angucken was es für neue neue features gibt was sie jetzt neu eingebaut haben und da sind schon ein paar ganz praktische geschichten dabei zum beispiel kann man jetzt einstellen dass wo stand es denn jetzt hier go genau man kann jetzt einstellen dass man virtual walls aufstellen kann für den staubsauger ach siehbarer sind es tatsächlich sind es 50 ja meine vorschau geht nicht richtig deswegen sehe ich das mit den subs irgendwie nur so halb ganz merkwürdig meine vorschau hat gerade ungefähr 0,3%
fps aktualisiert sich so alle zwei sekunden war jetzt jetzt vielleicht besser keine ahnung was mit meiner vorschau abgeht und es wiederum spackt ist auch egal man kann jetzt zum beispiel virtual walls hinstellen wo der staubsauger roboter dann nicht hinfährt das ist sehr nice zum beispiel ich bei mir sieht es ja so aus im ersten stock habe ich ja hier quasi
es kommt gerade paint skills aber hier ist dann da ist der flur der flur ist ungefähr so hier ist mein arbeitszimmer hier ist das wohnzimmer hier ist das schlafzimmer und so weiter und hier die treppe vom erdgeschoss rauf und der staubsauger hat zwar wohnungsumriss liegt ja der staubsauger achso hier hinten ist auch noch ein zimmer da ist auch noch ein zimmer so ungefähr ungefähr sieht das aus
und das schlafzimmer sogar ein bisschen länger ja so ungefähr so sieht das ganze aus und der kann ganz gut hin und her fahren der hat aber auch einen sensor dass er die treppe nicht runterfällt allerdings was man jetzt machen kann man kann jetzt hier einstellen man kann jetzt hier einstellen so ein no go area dass er gar nicht versucht hier hinten zu fahren weil hier kommt er eh nicht richtig hin da spackt er manchmal ein bisschen rum und der versucht dann immer wieder die treppe anzufahren weil das irgendwie nicht checkt dass es dann nicht weiter geht
der fährt dann hier lang ich fall runter zurück ich fall runter zurück ich fall runter zurück ich fall runter zurück und dann hier ist neben so ein geländer da kommt er aber unten drunter durch da versucht er es auch jedes mal so oh nee ich fall runter zurück ich fall runter zurück total sinnlos dem kann man jetzt einfach auf der map markieren no go area und dann sollte er das nicht mehr machen das probieren wir gleich mal aus ob das ganze funktioniert man kann jetzt über mqtt also hier über mqtt kann man jetzt nachrichten verschicken dass der staubsauger irgendwie losfährt zu irgendeiner
zone oder sowas brauche ich jetzt nicht der editor ist neu das finde ich ganz gut man kann jetzt nämlich auf der map der staubsauger legt ja eine karte von der wohnung an auf der map kann man jetzt direkt per drag and drop die zonen definieren wo er hinfahren soll ja dann zieht man beispielsweise in ein viereck zumindest man zieht es ja hier glaube ich im pull request
pull request
ach ja guck mal die haben ja sogar bildchen dabei
genau
genau man kann jetzt hier so einstellen hier da da sollst du sauber machen und man kann das ding benennen zum beispiel keine ahnung wohnzimmer und das kann man direkt auf der karte editieren das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch mach mal ausrufezeichen 1 ready dann wird das dann wird das erklärt 1 ausgeschrieben das kriegen wir ja das ist der loop filter so und als nächstes gibt es noch wir brauchen übrigens noch ein emote habe ich gesehen wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch dings hier wir brauchen noch
Den halben, das halbe Kappa-Ding, das brauchen wir noch.
Kapp.
Kapp brauchen wir noch.
Ach, ist schon, ist schon.
Lass mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Funktioniert, Kapp.
Kapp.
Ja, funktioniert.
Ach, sehr schön.
Ja, und wenn man, wenn es stimmt, was der Sibaro sagt, das muss ich mir nachher nochmal angucken.
Aber wir gehen mal davon aus, weil der Sibaro erzählt ja eigentlich, ne.
Außer, dass der nachts sehr merkwürdige Bilder im Discord postet.
Und, ähm, kann man sich ja in der Regel drauf verlassen, was er sagt.
Deswegen werde ich nachher mal 5 Euro an das Projekt donaten.
Und dann kriegen wir 50 Emotes.
Und dann brauchen wir natürlich noch die üblichen Twitch-Sub.
Übrigens, ich brauche für Twitch, brauche ich noch einen ordentlichen Prefix für meine Emotes.
Das war mir vorher gar nicht klar.
Man darf sich selbst auswählen.
Sektor cleared, Prime-Sub, sehr nice.
Übrigens, bei der Gelegenheit, falls ihr einen Prime-Account habt, jetzt erstmal eine Runde Sellout starten.
Falls ihr einen Prime-Account habt bei Amazon, man kann den mit Twitch verbinden.
Man bekommt dann jede Menge Lootboxen und, nein, Prime-Loot heißt das Ganze.
Allerdings kann man auch einen Streamer einmal im Monat mit einem Tier 1-Sub kostenlos unterstützen.
Kommt zu bald frei.
Also, wie gesagt, muss ja keiner, ne.
Ich erwähne es bloß mal nebenbei, weil bisschen Sellout, easy Sellout, easy life.
Easy.
So, ähm, ach Moment.
Ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss.
Ich muss ja mein, mein PPGA-Board ist ja noch gar nicht gestartet.
Jetzt krieg ich ja gar keine Fragen im Chat mit.
Moment.
Erstmal starten.
Lootboxen.
Ja, wie, wie sagt ein Twitch dazu oft?
Das ist, das ist Prime-Loot oder sowas, ne.
Oder Twitch Prime-Loot oder, ne, Prime-Loot heißt es.
Okay, dämlich und bescheuert, damit komme ich als Erklärung klar.
Ja, das ist, äh, ist halt so, ne.
Was willst du, was willst du sagen?
Es ist, es ist halt, es ist halt so.
Ich hab mir das mal irgendwann so angewöhnt, immer Zeug zu kopieren und, äh, das ist halt so.
Und wenn man sich mal an sowas gewöhnt hat, dann ist es auch schwierig, sich das wieder abzugewöhnen.
Außerdem wozu, ne.
Der Eufy ist super.
Ah, sehr schön.
Ah, das hat er gestern gepostet.
Das ist, Moment, das ist von gestern.
Direkt als Autostart, doch, könnte man machen.
Genau, was ist es, was, was gibt es sonst noch Neues in der Firmware?
Also ich hab aktuell Version 3.
3 plus ein paar Patches.
Und jetzt installieren wir Version 4.
Ähm.
Das geht übrigens nur für Generation 2.
Aber ich hab hier einen Generation 2 Staubsauger.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Man kann jetzt SSH-Keys direkt über das Webinterface hochladen.
Das war immer ein bisschen gefuddelt, wenn man die SSH-Keys verkehrt hat.
Und man kann irgendwie über das Webinterface Versionsupdates machen oder sowas.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Weil das Flashen über den Raspberry ist immer nervig.
Ähm.
Was für ein Staubsauger habe ich?
Steht doch im Titel.
Ähm, einen.
Den da.
Also ich hab zwei aktuell.
Ich hab einen Eufy 11.
Und ich hab einen.
Einen Roborock S50.
Ähm.
Der hier ist natürlich klar der bessere.
Der kostet aber auch 2-3 mal je nach Angebot so viel.
Robocock.
Alter Chat.
Twitch Chat wieder.
Äh.
Wieder.
Ah.
Haha.
Wirechamp.
Äh.
Und der Eufy ist ganz praktisch.
Also der da.
Der Eufy.
Der Eufy ist ganz praktisch.
Der ist nämlich sehr flach.
Der passt auch unter alle Schränke und so.
Und ich machs jetzt immer so.
Der macht eigentlich alles inklusive Flur.
Und der kriegt auch richtig gut, richtig gut Katzenstreu und sowas alles weg im Flur.
Ähm.
Und der ist halt auch schnell, weil er die Räume abscannt.
Und den Eufy setz ich dann ab und zu nur nochmal ins Schlafzimmer und überall da wo Schränke
und was ist wo der andere nicht richtig drunter kommt.
Da darf der Eufy dann auch ein bisschen im Kreis fahren.
Im Zickzack.
Weil der Eufy ist ziemlich dumm.
Der fährt immer gegen die Wand.
Pfff.
Nächste Ecke.
Nächste Ecke. Pfff.
Und so weiter.
Und der ist halt schlauer.
Der scannt den Raum ab per Laser.
So.
Was das Katzenstreu soll auch in eine Kiste und nicht einfach in Flur.
Die Katze die hält sich da aber nicht dran.
Die sitzt dann da drauf und macht dann erstmal ihren Haufen rein und dann wird gescharrt
und dann fliegt halt das Katzenstreu mit raus.
Da kannst du nichts dagegen machen.
Da.
Die da.
Eufy kostet zu 179 auf Amazon.
Hast du nicht zwei Katzen?
Ne hab ich nicht.
So.
Und ähm.
Was gibt es sonst noch so für schöne Changes?
Äh.
Kommt der Roborock S50 auch mit Räumen klar?
Wo ein Teppichübergang ist?
Ja.
Der kommt damit ziemlich gut klar.
Der hat sogar einen extra Teppichmodus wo er hochdreht.
Also man kann das so einstellen dass der erkennt.
Man kann das auch einstellen wie empfindlich das ist.
Dass der erkennt wenn er jetzt auf ein bisschen dichtere Teppiche drauf fährt.
Dann fährt er halt auf den Teppich drauf.
Und du merkst sobald er auf dem Teppich ist fängt er halt an.
Und saugt sich einen ab.
Memory leak was fixed.
Siehste mal.
So weit sind wir schon.
2019.
Da kann ich ja der Staubsauger Memory leaken.
Und wieso routest du den Robo in der dass ich die Custom Firmware drauf machen kann?
Weil die Original Firmware geht nur mit offizieller App.
Und es ist ja nicht nur das du nur die offizielle App brauchst.
Du brauchst die offizielle App und die Verbindung geht immer über die Cloud in China.
Und ich hab keinen Bock das mein Staubsauger eine Cloudverbindung nach China braucht.
Better looking default map ist auch ok.
Probier mal einfach mal aus.
Ja so siehts aus.
Aber ich kann das Ding empfehlen und es gibt das ab und zu mal relativ günstig.
Das ist ja nicht mal das aktuellste Modell von denen.
Es gibt ja jetzt schon einen S6.
Der S6 hat das Problem das es glaube ich noch keine Custom Firmware gibt.
Wobei müssen wir mal schauen ob es für den S6 mittlerweile schon eine Firmware Version gibt.
Support for S6.
Vor 15 Tagen.
Warum kriegt der?
Warum kriegt der Typ einen Daumen runter?
Das ist doch eine vollkommen legitime Frage für das Projekt.
So nach dem Motto ja wir sind ein Projekt für Roborock Staubsauger.
Ja ist der Roborock S60 supported?
Daumen runter.
Disabo.
Routing discussing should be done over in Dustcloud.
Woher soll denn das der Dude denn wissen?
Da würde ich auch nicht drauf kommen.
Ok gucken wir mal ob wir den S6 schon.
Warum heißt der denn da T6?
Offiziell heißt der S6.
Wired Champion.
Was ist denn ein guter Preis für den S50?
400€ ist viel zu viel.
Ich habe den damals bei einem Angebot bei Amazon gekriegt.
Ich glaube für um die 300€.
Ich müsste mal nachgucken was meiner gekostet hat.
Aber wir gucken einfach mal bei Guides Hals.
Ich guck mal kurz nebenbei in den Mails was meiner gekostet hat bei Amazon.
Guck mal in der Vorschau ist er sogar schon drinne.
Ähm.
Mal gucken mit welcher E-Mail Adresse habe ich denn das bestellt.
Alternate.
Oh man was man da für E-Mails findet.
Die will man überhaupt nicht finden wenn man nach Alternate sucht.
Feels merkwürdig Champ.
Wenn ich nach Alternate suche warum finde ich dann 100.000 Werbemails?
Was ist das denn?
E-Mail Volltext suche in 2019.
Ähm.
Ok.
Ich finde es gerade nicht.
Ich glaube ich habe irgendwas um 300 oder 320 oder irgendwie sowas bezahlt.
Das war ein ziemlich gutes Angebot.
Das steht hier gar nicht drinne.
Das gab es mal als Angebot.
Das ist er doch.
Ja viel zu teuer.
Viel zu teuer.
Also ich würde gucken dass ich auf jeden Fall unter 350 kriege.
Am besten irgendwas für Richtung 300.
Weil alles andere ist dann nicht mehr so Schnäppchen mäßig.
Und auf jeden Fall gucken.
Es gibt einen S5.
Es gibt einen.
Die haben irgendwie 4 verschiedene.
Also man muss gucken dass es der S50 ist.
Und man muss gucken auch das es nicht der S6 ist.
Weil den S6 kann man nicht flashen.
So ein Smoker.
Das hier ist viel viel zu teuer.
ETF.
Muss man auf ein gutes Angebot warten.
Aber ich kann ihn auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Guck hier gibt es den zum Beispiel ab 369.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also für 280 würde ich den sofort kaufen.
Aber das ist bestimmt Skamast.
Hä?
Also zumindest das Angebot sieht nicht nach Skamast.
Also es sieht jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht ultra Skamast aus.
Also 280 Euro ist ein absolut Hammer Angebot.
Wenn das dann auch wirklich funktioniert.
Ach das ist die erste.
Die können sich nicht entscheiden.
Moment.
Die erste Generation sackt.
Erste Generation sackt.
Auf jeden Fall zweite Generation.
Aber die erste Generation ist doch glaube ich gar nicht.
Ist 50 oder?
Was?
Was oben hast du das Modell zur Auswahl?
Ne das ist die Stückzahl.
Ach hier da.
Hier 50.
Ah ja da kommen wir der Sache schon näher.
374.
Omega lol.
Ne so nicht.
Skamast.
Ja.
Also ich würde gucken dass ich einen unter 350 kriege.
Auf jeden Fall.
Dann kann man sich da drüber Gedanken machen.
Ob das nicht.
Dann ist es ein ganz gutes Angebot.
Tübeidet.
Ja.
Massive Tübeid.
Ok.
Als erstes.
Müssten wir.
Wie wenig komischen Papagei noch drin habe.
Naja.
Wie die Maus war.
Als erstes.
Muss ich jetzt mal mein Raspberry holen.
Anschließen.
Weil.
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Dann muss ich jetzt mal meinen Raspberry holen.
Weil.
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ging der Flash Vorgang.
Ungefähr so in der Richtung.
Wir müssen uns mal.
Die hat eine ganz gute Anleitung.
Auf der Seite.
Also wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ging das ungefähr so.
Man hat sich.
Einen.
Image.
Runtergeladen.
Vom Hersteller.
Was bringt dir das.
Flashen.
Um.
Ungeflasht.
Braucht das Ding.
Die offizielle App.
Vom Hersteller.
Und.
Die.
Das wäre alle.
Alleine.
Wäre noch nicht so.
Schlimm.
Aber.
Die offizielle.
App.
Vom Hersteller.
Staubsauger, sondern geht immer über die Cloud
in China und zum Staubsauger.
Also sowohl dein Staubsauger braucht permanente
Verbindung zur China-Cloud, als auch die App braucht
permanente Verbindung zur China-Cloud.
Und wenn die China-Cloud nicht geht, kannst du deine Wohnung nicht sauber
machen. Geschweige denn, dass ich eigentlich
auch gar nicht will, dass mein
Staubsauger in der China-Cloud hängt.
Und wenn du den flashst, ist die China-Cloud weg.
Das ist richtig beknackt,
Sneakypile. Das ist total bescheuert.
Oh, ich hab einen Prime-Sub vergessen.
Kalumina01.
Danke schön, Twitch Prime am Start.
Pock.
Internet of Shit, ja, ist tatsächlich so.
Wir machen mal
einen Twitter-Post, weil sich ja wieder
letztens Leute auf Twitter beschwert haben,
dass sie nicht mitbekommen haben.
Sag mal, habt ihr alle schon das neue Twitter-Design?
Ich bekomm das nicht.
Ich bekomm nicht das neue Twitter-Design.
Ist das machbar für jemanden, der
keine Ahnung hat? Du kannst einfach mal zugucken.
Ich denke schon, dass
es machbar ist für jemanden, der keine Ahnung hat.
Allerdings sollte man sich nicht
sollte man ein bisschen Zeit einplanen.
Ich kann's nicht zeigen, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin
hier auf Twitter. Ich hab noch das
alte Design, wo es oben
wo die Knöpfe oben sind,
wo die Knöpfe oben Startseite, Mitteilung, Nachrichten sind.
Das neue Design hat die Knöpfe ja
links an der Seite.
Okay, hab ich mal die Sache auf Twitter
gepostet.
Könnte es eigentlich auch so machen, dass es automatisch
eine Twitter-Nachricht schickt, wenn man
wenn man on geht. Das wär vielleicht auch gar nicht so blöd.
Also zumindest, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab,
wie das Ganze funktioniert hat.
Man braucht auf jeden Fall irgendein Gerät,
das, wo man Access Points
drin aufmachen kann.
Also man braucht einen, man braucht einen Raspberry.
Man oder hat irgendein anderes Gerät.
Man kann auch sein Desktop nehmen mit einem USB-Stick,
mit einem WLAN-USB-Stick oder sowas in der Richtung.
So, und wie das Ganze so grob funktioniert hat,
wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Man lädt sich die letzte aktuelle Firmware runter
vom Hersteller.
Und dann lädt man so ein Gerät auf, wie das Ganze funktioniert hat.
Dann lädt man sich von GitHub,
wir machen gleich die Anleitung mal durch.
Dann lädt man sich von GitHub so einen
Riesenskript runter,
was die Firmware modifiziert.
Und als letztes lädt man sich dann auch hier dieses
Valu-Dingsbums. Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken,
wenn man das ausspricht.
ValuTudo runter.
Das ist ein Go-Programm und baut das in die Firmware ein.
Dann muss man das Ganze Flashen.
Wo ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher bin ist,
ob man die Firmware auf seinem Desktop bauen konnte.
Ob man die Firmware auf seinem Desktop bauen konnte.
Oder ob man sie dann auch im Desktop baut, so wieuu..
Oder ob man die Firmware auf dem Raspberry bauen musste.
Ich glaube, man konnte die Firmware auf dem Desktop bauen und dann auf dem Raspberry kopieren.
Neui, so einen habe ich auch noch.
Der ist auch an sich ganz gut.
Gerade dafür, dass er halt so blöde ist und halt nicht super intelligent, sondern einfach nur die Ecken abfährt.
Ich finde es an sich auch ganz gut, wenn die Dinger ohne großartige Cloud-Anbindung oder sowas daherkommen.
Aber in dem Fall ist es halt so.
Und das Gerät kann halt auch deutlich mehr.
Das kann beispielsweise die Räume scannen mit einem Laser, dass der weiß, wie groß der Raum ist und fährt den dann halt auch gezielt ab.
Also wenn ich mir meinen Eufy angucke.
Der Eufy braucht fürs Wohnzimmer drüben, keine Ahnung, eine halbe Stunde, bis der das ordentlich sauber gemacht hat.
Weil der halt komplett planlos random fährt.
Der S5...
Der S5-50 braucht richtig ordentlich mit Teppichmodus 10 Minuten.
Das ist halt schon ein Unterschied, ob das Ding random den Raum zickzack durchfährt oder ob das Ding den Raum geplant durchfährt.
Wir gucken uns das dann auch gleich an, wenn er rumfährt.
So, also wie ging denn der ganze Kram nochmal?
Habe ich vielleicht noch irgendwo was hier vom letzten...
Der Rout...
Warte.
S5.
Ähm, habe ich hier vielleicht noch...
S5-50, noch das alte Verzeichnis irgendwo drauf.
Ähm...
Firmware, wie könnte ich das geladen haben?
Ich glaube, das habe ich noch mal drauf.
Fuck.
Okay, dann muss ich das komplett, komplett neu runterladen, den ganzen Mist.
So, Laurens, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Nice-u.
Okay.
Currently the following device...
Blablabla.
Wie, wie, was?
Wir empfehlen...
Wir empfehlen die folgende Firmware für den...
Für den Vorgang.
Firmware V1111001782.
Okay.
Nice.
Machen wir.
Äh, Introduction.
Kann man lesen, oder?
Hallo, Tommy K.
Kann man eigentlich ganz gut lesen, jetzt hier, von der Größe her.
Ähm...
How this works, blablabla.
Local Interface, blablabla.
So, das ist die technische Erklärung dahinter, wie sie es machen.
How installation works.
Encrypted but unsigned Firmware-Image.
Encryption Key, was, was, Frauen, blablabla.
User has to download Firmware-Image from Manufacturer.
Ja, das machen wir.
Und patched them.
Genau, das war der Act.
Also, man musste...
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Man musste vom Hersteller sich...
Man musste sich irgendwo einen Download suchen von der Firmware vom Hersteller.
Und dann musste man die modifizieren mit dem Patch.
Oh, Leute, ich muss mal die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Es ist übelst warm hier drin.
Mode.
Aller Klimaanlage.
Geh mal auf kühlen.
Kühlen.
Ja, jetzt.
Alles.
Ähm, so.
Dependencies, das haben wir bestimmt alles.
Root Access.
If you plan on being able to connect to your SSH.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen wir nicht, weil in Version 4 kann man den SSH-Key hochladen.
Über das Webinterface.
Max, welche GPU empfiehlst du für 1080p, 144Hz Gaming?
Ähm.
Ich beschäftige mich mit Grafikkarten und Zeug eigentlich in der Regel immer nur, wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe.
Allerdings, wenn ich mir jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufen würde, nach allem, was ich gelesen habe,
würde ich wahrscheinlich eine 2070 oder sowas kaufen.
Oder ich würde wieder anfangen, Videos zu machen und mir von Nvidia eine 2080D geben lassen.
Das ist nämlich Next Level.
Okay, Image Building.
Also wir müssen jetzt als erstes mal uns irgendwo das Hersteller-Image runterladen, oder?
Ne, ne, wir laden keine fertige Images runter, wir machen das selbst.
Okay, also.
MkDiA-Robo.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob man das auf dem Desktop oder auf dem Raspberry machen musste.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen es mal auf dem Raspberry, weil auf dem brauchen wir den Kram bis am Ende eh.
Ich stöpsel mal kurz den Raspberry ein.
Warte mal kurz.
Oh mein Gott.
So.
Raspberry.
Okay, das Ding startet.
Da machen wir das nämlich auf dem Raspberry, ist besser.
Gut.
Hi, Ed.
Na, hoffen wir mal, dass er die gleiche IP kriegt, wie das letzte Mal.
Muss ich erstmal nachgucken, was er für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Komm.
Come on, bruh.
Oh ne.
Eine andere IP gekriegt.
Muss ich mal kurz ins DHCP gucken.
DHCP-Leases.
Raspberry, was hat er denn gekriegt?
Ne Hund.
Ich hab die auch richtig bescheuert.
Ich hab das doch jetzt nicht im WLAN, sondern per Netzwerkstecker dran.
Jetzt sind wir auf dem richtigen drauf.
Statisches DHCP.
Äh, ich glaube, ich hab sogar statisches DHCP für das Ding.
Allerdings hab ich gerade das falsche Netz probiert.
So, machen wir mal ein Update von dem Ding.
Man weiß ja nie.
Beim Vierer tut sich ja da auch noch recht viel.
Go, go.
Lohnt sich der Vierer?
Naja.
Also, nur in Ausnahmefällen.
Nur in Ausnahmefällen.
Die Ausnahmefällen sind, würde ich sagen, ähm, Media Center.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich, ich würde den Raspberry auch nicht als Media Center verwenden.
Vielleicht den Vierer, das müsste ich mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich finde, da sollte man sich einfach einen günstigen Android-TV-Stick kaufen und glücklich sein.
Und das läuft dann in der Regel viel besser.
Ähm, als Media Center würde ich den Vierer nehmen, wenn es unbedingt ein Raspberry sein muss.
Ähm, ich würde den Vierer nehmen, wenn es unbedingt ein Raspberry sein muss.
Falls ich irgendwelche Anzeigewände habe, was wahrscheinlich die wenigsten hier haben,
dann würde ich den Vierer nehmen.
Oder wenn ich ein ganz, ganz billiges NAS bauen will und halt die USB- und Netzwerkübertragungsraten bräuchte.
Aber dafür ist er eigentlich an sich nicht geeignet.
Allein schon, weil du keine Verschlüsselung gescheit mitmachen kannst, weil er dafür viel zu lahm ist.
Oder es liegt am 32-Bit-Raspbian, weil die ARM-CPU ihre Encryption, äh, Crypto-Extensions nur unter 64-Bit verwenden kann.
Wie viele Subs gab hr heute schon? Ich glaube, 4 oder 5.
Übrigens gestern! Total übertrieben, ne?
Ich hab gestern mal nachgeguckt. Ich guck mal, wie viele Subs ich jetzt hab.
Gestern nachgeguckt und ich hab ja so im Stream gesagt, ah, werden so 30 oder so gewesen sein.
52!
Huge!
Noch, noch mehr Subs!
Hier, der GWOTZ3ZKUSCHRENADA, ah ja.
Ähm, Twitch Prime!
Ja, wenn ich irgendwann mal, ähm, keine Ahnung, 40.000 Subs oder so hab, Shroud hat 40.000 Subs, ne, hab ich letztens irgendwo gelesen, 40.000 Subs ist schon ziemlich pock, Reaction-Streams, ja, ich hab doch letztens, haben wir doch einen Stream gemacht, wo ich irgendwie, letzten Sonntag, hab ich noch einen Stream gemacht, wo ich gesagt hab, irgendwie Aufwach-Stream, wo wir uns ein paar Videos angeguckt haben, das war ja so eine Art Reaction-Stream,
und, da hatte ich auf einmal voll viele Zuschauer, so aus dem Nichts, 100 Subs Face-Reveal, ne, 5.000 Subs Face-Reveal, 5.000 Subs Face-Reveal, oder 1.000.000 Abos auf YouTube, auf Face-Reveal, easy.
Gehst du einfach auf den Boden schlafen und streamst, da ist schon, ich guck X2Z wirklich gern, ähm, der ist halt, der hat halt so seine eigene, seine eigene Art irgendwie,
das zu machen, ich find's halt, ich, ich find's halt übelst lustig, ne, vor allem, wenn er zwischendrin auf seinen Stuhl springt und irgendwie da drauf rumschweißt, also,
ich mein, ich kann's mir nicht den ganzen Tag angucken, aber ich find's zwischendurch echt lustig.
Der 300k-Hype-Train, ich krieg aktuell auf YouTube, krieg ich schon wieder massig D-Abos, einfach weil ich nichts hochlade, mit 300k ist da nix auf YouTube, ne, ne.
Wie, es gibt keine Updates, das glaub ich nicht.
Für den Vierer gab's täglich Updates normalerweise.
Warum, warum, warum, warum gibt's keine Updates?
Okay, ich will mich nicht beschweren, dass es keine Updates gibt.
Man kann nicht abonnieren, ja, seit gestern, seit gestern, irgendwie 17 Uhr oder so, hat Twitch, äh, war Twitch der Meinung, wir schalten's jetzt frei.
Also, ja.
Ich mein, überlegt euch's mal, für die Größe vom Stream, ne, und bei der ganzen Zeit sind es 52 Subs, ist echt schon, das ist, äh, huge.
Aber ich hab halt BigBrain-Subs.
Die wissen halt, was sie tun.
Die wissen halt, was ich gehör.
Der Sebaro war einer der Ersten, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der Sebaro der Erste war.
Sebaro, soll ich mal nachgucken, ob du der Erste warst?
Da, Frank, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Sebaro, ich guck mal, ob du der Erste warst.
Subscriber History.
Wer war der Erste?
Der Sebaro war der Erste, tatsächlich.
Allerdings nur ganz knapp.
Nur ganz knapp.
Ähm.
Sebaro war der Erste, danach kam direkt der SilentPain.
Und dann kam der Patrick.
Der war aber ein paar Minuten später.
Twitch Prime Sellout, ja.
Hab ich schon.
Einmal die Stunde reicht, würd ich sagen.
Okay, also, wie funktioniert denn der ganze Krams jetzt hier?
MKDier, Roborock, alles gut, jawoll, bla, blub.
Clone-Dust-Cloud-Repo.
Until Image-Bilder 0.1 is available.
Okay, was auch immer, wir klonen das jetzt einfach.
So ist es.
Ich sag euch was, Klimaanlage ist wirklich angenehm.
Fällt mir jedes Mal auf, wenn so was passiert.
So warm ist es, du drückst einfach auf den Knopf und fünf Minuten später ist es kühl.
Ja, Zugucker, ich werd's überleben.
Ich werd's überleben.
Okay, haben wir den Kram geklaut.
Create Directory, jawoll.
Push.
Das ist jetzt aber die Oldschool-Variante, ja.
Download Latest Binary From.
Machen wir auch.
Da.
0.4 Beta wollen wir runterladen.
Guck mal, hier haben sie auch noch ein paar Bilder von den neuen Funktionen.
Das ist der Zonen-Editor.
Das ist hier auch Zonen-Editor.
Noch mehr Zonen-Editor.
Äh, Access-Code.
Ach, endlich!
Sie haben jetzt, sie haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, dass man sich authentifiziert am Webinterface.
Ja, das ist gut.
Aktuell ist es nämlich so, jeder, der auf den Staubsauger-Roboter draufkommt, also jeder, der in diesem WLAN drin ist, kann das Ding steuern.
Ich mein, bei mir ist es kein Ding.
Ich hab nen extra WLAN für die ganzen China-Geräte.
Aber für, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, normale Leute, die vielleicht die Geräte auch brauchen.
Bei sich ins WLAN hängen, äh, gibst die irgendeinem Kollege oder so, mein, dein WLAN-Passwort, und der steuert dann an Staubsauger durch die Wohnung.
Sie haben es jetzt, jetzt haben sie es wohl geschafft, dass du, ähm, dass du den Staubsauger auch, ähm, basic, also Passwort-Authentifizierung schützen kannst.
Und dass man endlich SSH-Keys direkt hochladen kann.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr sehr, ja, wo ist es?
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, ja, wo ist es?
Äh, und sonst gibt es eigentlich nichts Neues.
Okay, wir sollen die neueste Version runterladen.
Das da.
Copy Link.
EGET.
Bam.
Erstmal 30 Millionen Zeichen-Uhr.
Okay, runtergeladen.
Instructions.
Download.
Deployment.
Warum können wir nicht einfach ein CD machen?
Warum müssen wir ein Push-D machen?
Achso, wir machen ein Push-D, dass man nach dem nachher wieder nach oben gehen kann.
Das ist aber, das habe ich schon ewig nicht mal gesehen.
Dass das jemand verwendet.
Äh, und jetzt müssen wir die ConfRAW runterladen.
Okay, auch gut.
Machen wir.
ETC.
WEGET.
Hosts.
Zack.
RCLocal.
Wir machen jetzt einfach POP.
POPT.
So.
Create Firmware Directory.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal die Anleitung durch.
Ich habe das ja schon mal gemacht vor ein paar Monaten.
Das hat auch soweit funktioniert.
Download latest Firmware.
WEGET URL.
Ah.
Example.
Okay, da oben stand auch, was die für eine Firmwareversion empfehlen.
1782.
Also, ja, dann passt die URL doch eigentlich.
Dieser Moment, wenn der Staubzauger SSH hat.
Ja, hat er.
Hat er ja aktuell auch schon.
Also, ich kann mich aktuell.
Ich zeige, ich zeige das mal, weil ich habe den ja hier schon.
Ach nee, ich habe ihn gerade ausgeschaltet.
Moment, WEGET.
WEGET.
Moment, wo, wo, wo sind da stehen geblieben?
Ähm.
Hier.
WEGET.
Resolving.
Connecting.
Waiting.
President Sleeper hier.
Was hast du für eine Klimaanlage?
Irgendeine von Mitsubishi Heavy.
Den genauen Typ kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Langsame Urlaube.
Ja, kann sein.
Aber ich starte jetzt nicht nochmal.
Die eineinhalb Minuten können wir warten.
Das ist nicht GitHub.
Das ist von Amazon.
Legt da runter.
Welches Linux ist das?
Das ist von Amazon.
Das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM als Desktop.
Das stimmt, da haben wir sogar einen Befehl dafür.
Ich hoffe es smog danach nicht.
Manjaro Install gestern gefailt.
Mit was?
Was die Manjaro Install gefailt?
But why?
Ach, das habe ich im Discord gesehen.
Ja, das hat mir auch nichts gesagt.
Was hast du für einen Installer genommen?
Den minimalen Net Install?
Damit hatte ich eigentlich noch keine Probleme bisher.
Ubuntu.
Ubuntu immer noch beste.
Auf dem Server, ja.
Ich weiß, ich finde es witzig, ne?
Die halbe Welt verwendet Ubuntu auf dem Desktop.
Ich finde Ubuntu auf dem Desktop suckt.
Auf dem Desktop verwende ich Manjaro.
Die andere halbe Welt verwendet auf dem Server Red Hat oder irgendwelche Abkömmlinge davon.
Debian.
Das war es eigentlich zum größten Teil.
Manche haben noch Zuse oder sowas.
Aber eigentlich hast du Debian.
Und Red Hat zum größten Teil.
Und da verwende ich Ubuntu Server.
Ubuntu Server beste.
Ok, Download fertig.
Nice.
Oh, ich habe es falsch heruntergeladen.
Habe ich das falsch heruntergeladen?
Ne, ne, ne.
Ich habe es richtig heruntergeladen.
Passt.
If you follow above commands, your RoboDirectoryStructure should look like this.
Gucken wir mal, wie meine RoboDirectoryStructure aussieht.
So.
bla bla, okay passt
Firmware, ja
Fale
Tuto, das ist echt der Zungenbrecher
der Name, ich weiß nicht warum
die hätten das anders nennen sollen, ich finde das ist
voller Zungenbrecher, die hätten das Projekt irgendwie
Robo-Own
oder, oder keine Ahnung
Roborock, Bashzor
oder was weiß ich auch
das ist voller Zungenbrecher
ähm, deployment
ähm
deployment, etc
bla bla, ja
ja, sieht gut aus, sieht gut aus
Creating Firmware Image
MKD Image
in welchem Verzeichnis
soll man das jetzt hier überhaupt anlegen
gar nicht hier, oder
weil die gehen ja hier eins nach oben
also irgendwie
in dem Verzeichnis sein, oder in dem
Verzeichnis
ne
in welchem Verzeichnis muss man dann sein
ach ne, der wechselt dann da rein
achso, naja, okay, dann passt
das schon
ähm, okay, also jetzt bilden wir mal das Firmware Image
scroll nochmal hoch
was ist hier in der Anleitung?
Moin, Homewell?
achso, und übrigens
ähm, der Chat besteht
drauf, dass ich Ubuntu nicht Ubuntu
ausspreche, sondern Ju- ne, fuck
wie, Moment, wie muss ich
Ubuntu aussprechen?
ich hab's vergessen
wie muss ich Ubuntu aussprechen?
Ubuntu, genau, Ubuntu
oh, hier ist ne Motte
hier ist
da krabbelt ne Motte rum, ich muss mal kurz
platt, platt, platt machen
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hat sie natürlich so toll gekrabbelt
dass ich nicht drankomme
come on, brah, wartet mal
Mottebash
Mottenbash
wo ist es hin? wo ist das Viech hin?
wo ist das Viech hin?
ich komm da net hin
debated
ich komm da nicht hin, das ist total
total beschissen hinterm Monitor, ey
fuck
hm, wartet mal
Snipesaw, genau
360 quickscoped
äh, jetzt springt das Ding hier
total rum
wo ist es hin?
da, da springt's
das jumpt voll, das jumpt voll über den Tisch
debated
okay, ich hab, ich hab keine Ahnung
wo es hin ist, ich hab's nicht erwischt
muss ich nachher nochmal gucken
wo es hin ist
aber ich hab's teilweise, ich hab's so halb erwischt
weil wenn das, weil wenn das, äh
wenn ich das nicht erwischt hätte, dann würd's nicht rumspringen
sondern wegfliegen
hab ich hier so ne halb
platte Motte rum, rum
hüpfen
die Katz find, nein die
Chico ist nicht in der Lage das zu fangen
äh, die ist da viel zu
noobcat für
wobei, gibt's nicht nen Stream, an der noobcat heißt?
okay, also, jetzt müssen wir
das
Firmware-Image generieren
okay, machen wir das mal, warum muss man das eigentlich
als root machen, muss man bestimmt nicht als root machen
wär doch irgendwie beknackt
achso, ja gut, wir sind auf dem Raspberry, wir sind eh root
keine andere Variante
replaceadb
exesysv
das Ding hat nen USB-Anschluss?
...
das hab ich überhaupt nicht gesehen, dass man Staubsauger und USB-Anschluss hat
wüsste gar nicht, wo das sein soll
guck mal, nochmal ne Maschine, Steckdosen
keine Ahnung, wo überhaupt der USB-Anschluss
sein soll
okay, ah, auch gut
hier hagelt es gerade 5 cm, hör
Körner
ah, feels bad, man
einfach nicht rausgehen
easy
guck doch einfach bei deinem Gerät, ich weiß ja nicht, wo ich gucken soll
ich hab das Ding schon in der Hand gehabt
hab so ziemlich alles offen gehabt an dem Ding
ich hab keinen USB-Anschluss gesehen
okay, wir machen das jetzt mal kurz anders
wartet mal
ich soll mal ein ordentliches
ordentliches Kommando draus bauen
so, weg
Firmware, jawoll
Public Key, brauchen wir nicht
Path ist okay
ja, Firmware Upgrades Disable
auf jeden Fall
IP Server
60.1
der kommt ja in mein China
Wlan rein
Replace ADB, okay, fertig
alles jetzt kopiert
ja
ah, ich hab die Voraussetzung
nicht installiert, ich kack noob
okay, was
brauchen wir
was brauchen wir alles, Bash ist auf jeden Fall drauf
OpenSSH
SSH Keygen wird wahrscheinlich auch drauf sein
ähm
DOS to Unix
und CC
RIPT
okay, jetzt aber
okay, dann soll man für
No Public Key Selected
ich
ich will ja auch keine Keys
ich will auch überhaupt keine Keys
hä
wie, muss ich nen Key auswählen
oder was
ich will kein Key generieren, ich will den Key hochladen
übers Webinterface danach
okay, ähm
hab ich schon SSH generiert
SSH Key generiert
mal gucken
nee
Gott, generieren wir ein
gut, SSH, ja
nee, Moment, wir brauchen nen Special
Keygen
okay
wir generieren jetzt genau wie die das hier
wie die das hier vorgeben
yourmail.example.com
perfekt, so wollte ich schon immer, dass das heißt
okay, gut, dann
dann nochmal
.ssh
id, dieser Papp
passt das jetzt
ich hab's nicht, ich hab's auskommentiert
hm
hab ich doch
wartet mal
Firmware
ah, haha
falsche Versionsnummer
so, der Rest sollte jetzt aber stimmen
so, ha
ah, jetzt geht's los
dann erstellen wir mal ein Firmware Image
gleich, gleich gibt's MonkaSmoke
wir schauen mal wie der Raspberry
ausgelastet ist
oh na ja, ein CPU
kein 100%, das ist ja in Ordnung
wird gezippt
sorry, gesippt wird er
gesippt
wir müssen ja neuerdings alles geil englisch betont
aussprechen
wir haben auch keine API mehr, wir haben nur noch APIs
unter Ubuntu
wahrscheinlich ist danach die
die Micro SD Karte vom
Raspberry direkt im Arsch
meine Glocks HD
ai ja
oh man, Java, ja
das wird immer schlimmer
und auch Router
oh er ist fertig
war das echt so einfach
da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern
ich dachte das letzte mal hat das länger gedauert
und hat noch mehr Schritte gebraucht
aber vielleicht haben sie es ja einfach
verbessert
ok, jetzt haben wir ein Firmware Image generiert
flashing Firmware Image
after successful build on Firmware Image
using 4M
na wir usen keine 4M
wir usen
wir usen den Raspberry
first we need to create
a virtual environment for Python
Python Virtual Environment
ok, ist schon installiert
pip und vn
machen wir alles
das ist ja easy, ein Ding
alles installiert
und dann kommt der Flasher
oh
55 bits
dankeschön
huge
huge bits
so langsam aber sicher
brauche ich einen dritten Monitor
ich habe jetzt hier halt für das was ihr seht
habe ich links neben dran einen Monitor
da habe ich hier mein
Image Zeugs
und mein Sound Zeugs
dann habe ich Stream Vorschau
und Chat
und jetzt bräuchte ich eigentlich nochmal eine Anzeige
für ähm
Video Subs
und Bits und Donations
und Gedöns
weil ich werde garantiert wieder die Hälfte übersehen
wie ich das auch bei Follows immer gemacht habe
wieviel RAM hast du eigentlich gesamt
doch der Rechner hat
16 GB
also es ist jetzt nicht
es ist jetzt nicht so übermäßig viel
ich wollte mir ja noch
noch ein zweites Pack
16G kaufen
jetzt wo RAM gerade ein bisschen billiger ist
ok weiter jetzt CD Punkt Punkt
nicht CD Punkt Punkt
MkDia Flasher
kann fast ein CS GoPro sein
ähm
jawoll
neues VNV anlegen
jetzt müssen wir wahrscheinlich Activate machen
genau
VNV Activate
Install
das ist jetzt Python Gedöns das kann man einfach durchklicken
äh wieviel Euro
sind denn 50 Bits
ich habe gestern hat irgendjemand gesagt
im Stream 1 Bit ist 1 Cent
weiß ich ob das stimmt
jedenfalls ist das hier alles
Huge Money
Massive
Next
Gamer329 ich kann dir nicht ganz folgen
500 Bits
krasser Shit
von Pruppi
ist das was
Pruppi was ist denn das für ein Icon daneben an dir
Direct Relief Charity
oh man kriegt jetzt
man kann sogar Icons kriegen
für wahrscheinlich weil das irgendwas ist
das ist ja ein irgendein Speedrun Marathon oder
interessant wusste ich gar nicht das das geht
ok jetzt sind wir
Connect your Robots
Discover Handshake
na das geht jetzt
Moment das funktioniert jetzt also nicht
das funktioniert ja so nicht
ich muss jetzt ja erste mal
mein Raspberry zu dem gleichen Wlan
Connecten
wie
wie mach ich Moment wie mach ich das jetzt am besten
mein
mein Robo ist
ja schon angemeldet am Wlan
das heißt ich melde
jetzt einfach den Raspberry am gleichen Wlan
an wie der Robo und dann gucken wir mal
hm
probieren wir mal aus
ähm
ja machen wir mal
dann müssen wir erst mal Wlan Wlan verbinden
achso oh ne Leute jetzt muss ich euch ja wieder
ausschalten
jetzt muss ich euch ja wieder ausschalten dass ihr mein Wlan
Zeug nicht seht
FeelsBadMan
ich switch euch einfach auf die andere Sache auf die andere Seite
da habt ihr wenigstens
habt ihr wenigstens den Chat und seid nicht so allein
QChat
ok ähm
Network Options
Wifi
Germany
also das dauert jetzt so ne Minute dann sind wir wieder am Start
Please enter SSID
Please enter Password
da muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken
weil ich muss jetzt erst mal auf meinen
Unify Controller
oh das wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert
ich muss jetzt erst mal auf meinen Unify Controller
und die
die Client Isolation ausschalten
Isolation ausschalten
sorry Leute das braucht noch mal ein paar Minuten
Blackscreen
sonst ist zu viel zu viel leaked
Password not valid
äh ok
but why rum
Admin
ok
sehr schön
Settings
Networks
ok WLAN Password brauchen wir jetzt noch
Finish
ok und jetzt soll er sich zum WLAN connecten
wenn er sich zum WLAN connectet
kann ich euch wieder einschalten
und er hat sich zum WLAN connectet
Poggers
ok ich schalt euch wieder ein
ah es ist ja hier
kompliziert
ups
ok
also ich bin jetzt per WLAN verbunden
mit dem gleichen WLAN Passwort
wie der
wie der Roboter
wie der Staubsauger Roboter
ich guck mal ob es funktioniert
ging das
wie
wie discover
es kann aber sein das es nicht funktioniert
weil ich noch die Client
Isolation ausschalten muss
achso ähm
VN
Activate
naja geht nicht
wie ging das jetzt nochmal
ich hab nen Sub gekriegt gerade oder
Steffchrist hier eins
dankeschön
weißt du
ah hier
Guest Policies ausschalten
safe
so und jetzt konfiguriert er mein WLAN neu
und dann sollte es gleich
gleich funktionieren
ok wir müssen noch 2 Minuten warten
das das WLAN neu konfiguriert dann ist gut
naja guck der hat gerade keine WLAN
Verbindung
wir warten jetzt bis der wieder WLAN Verbindung hat
und dann probieren wir das ganze nochmal aus
und mir ist gerade aufgefallen ich habe den Roboter auch gar nicht angeschaltet
das hier Big Brain Move
versuchen das Ding zu flashen
wenn er gar nicht eingeschaltet ist
HACKZOR
Elite Hacker Man
Twitch Prime
Naisu
ok ich schalte den Roboter schon mal ein
kann ja nicht schaden wenn wir den schon mal einschalten
oh fuck
wo ist das?
ah ich hab mein
ich hab mein Audio Interface halt runter geschmissen
ok
Test Test
ja das ist blöd
wenn man mit dem Stuhl
und dem Headset auf durch den halben Raum fährt
Mick ist nicht
gemuted
hier
Huge Chebat
ich bin gerade mit dem Headset auf durch den halben Raum gefahren
zum Staubsauger Roboter
und ähm
hab das Zeug halt runter geschmissen
ok ich zieh jetzt mal das Headset aus
Leute der Chebat ist wirklich schlecht
ich weiß das ihr mich hört
ok Staubsauger Roboter ist an
Raspberry hat auch wieder eine
hat auch wieder eine IP
so und jetzt probieren wir mal ob das funktioniert
komm, come on
Service Discovery done
und jetzt?
jetzt hätte das eigentlich funktionieren müssen
warum geht das jetzt nicht?
warum geht das nicht?
ich hab doch kein Token
ich hab doch keine Ahnung wie mein Token ist
kann ich, ich versuch mal mit dem Ding direkt zu kommunizieren
mit dem Roboter, vielleicht ist er noch gar nicht an
ich guck mal meine DHCP leases
ob der
ob der Roboter überhaupt an ist
Robo, Roborock, da ist er
60, was hat er für eine IP
ah ich weiß woran das liegt Leute
ich hab eine Idee woran das liegt
ähm
wisst ihr woran das liegen könnte?
ich hab mein Netzwerkkabel dran
und ich hab WLAN Verbindung aufgebaut
also das könnte sein
dass das Ding versucht quasi bei mir
im Netzwerk raus zu kommunizieren
anstatt über WLAN
ähm
dann stöpsel ich WLAN jetzt ab
dann muss ich mich, ne ich stöpsel
ich stöpsel WLAN ab, also easy Leute
lass mal WLAN abstöpseln
ähm
wir verbinden uns jetzt per SSH auf den Raspberry
was aus irgendwelchen Gründen
nicht funktioniert
doch
und dann zieh ich das Kabel raus
ach Quatsch
wir machen mal TMAX auf
wer weiß, dass uns das Ding nicht abkackt
ähm Roborock
ok
ich zieh den Raspberry raus
ähm
Raspberry ist draußen
keine IP mehr
alles gut
ähm Flasher
Activate
Discover, Achtung Command Pro
ja BAM funktioniert
erst mal übelst ausflippen
Token
Token, äh
das Token sieht nicht
korrekt aus
und PSQL
ne nicht PS, doch PSQL
hm ok
ich mein
wir probieren es einfach mal aus
Token, Firmware
ok, IP
IP vom
ups
ich hab grad irgendwie meine
meine entfernen Taste abgemacht
wie auch immer
ähm
IP ist 60
was hab ich gesagt 60107
und das Token
ist
ernsthaft? ffff
ok
Update Firmware
Image
Output
Polo S
PK
ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Wonka Smoke
macht der jetzt was?
Hast du den Schaubsauger gesettet?
Ne, ah
ich hab ne Idee
man kann sich bestimmt im Web Interface
das Token anzeigen lassen
äh 60
was hab ich denn 107
Settings
Token
ahhhh
huge
ich glaub mit dem Token kann man nicht allzu viel anfangen
Firmware Update hier drüber
geht aber noch nicht
ok Update Firmware
ist das das offizielle Token
das ist das Token von meinem
Staubsauger
offizieller gehts nicht mehr
ok
die machen das von einem
Verzeichnis oben drüber
machen wir jetzt auch einfach mal
ok Leute
Bless RNG
Moment das haben wir gar nicht
das muss ich noch hinzufügen
Sekunde Bless RNG
warum hab ich das hier nicht
Bless RNG
den brauchen wir noch
Color Transparent
ok
er spricht
er hat mit mir gesprochen der Staubsauger
no request was made
ok
nochmal
oh Leute habt ihr es gehört
habt ihr es gehört
ich versuch euch das mal
so das man es hören kann
wartet mal kurz
stellen wir das mal auf den Schreibtisch
und ich stöpsel mich mal kurz ab und entwirre mein Mikro
da fällt auch mein Audio Interface nicht mehr runter
so jetzt
passt mal auf was er sagt
ich glaub wir haben nämlich ein Problem
ich halte euch jetzt mal ran so das ihr das hört
blablabla
habt ihr es gehört
der Akkustand ist zu niedrig
hört man das echt nicht
der hat gerade gesagt der Akkustand
ist zu niedrig
so jetzt habe ich euch dran gehalten
Akkustand ist zu niedrig
das sagt natürlich
versuchen sie das
Update erneut wenn der Akkustand
mindestens 20% beträgt
Staubsauger waifu
hm
was machen wir denn jetzt
ich würde sagen ich hole mal die Ladestation von unten
und setze ihn auf die Ladestation
vielleicht darf man nämlich updaten
wenn er lädt
ok ich bin in 2 Minuten wieder da
gleich wieder da
ich bin wieder da wisst ihr was wir noch vergessen haben
und es ist gut das das Firmaflash nicht funktioniert hat
ich glaube ich habe vergessen Wlan
Wlan Passwort und sowas
einzurichten für das Ding
vor welchem Schritt
muss man denn das Wlan Passwort machen
man muss doch bestimmt immer noch sein Wlan Passwort eingeben
was im letzten
ah
ah das der behält
ok der behält seine Settings
behält er seine Wlan Settings
nach dem Update
das Ding hat angeblich USB wenn das Flashen schief geht
ja ok
ich schließe mal kurz die Ladestation an
du musst jetzt eine China Steckdose verwenden für
ich darf hier nicht manuell
eindocken
er will selbst zum Dock fahren
er findet seinen Dock nicht
das ist ein halber Meter von ihm weg
das Dock
alter Kack Noob
sein Dock ist da drüben
halben Meter weg
ist der Staubsauger sehr laut?
nö
das ist echt ok
auf Dock an
ah jetzt ist er
ok jetzt ist er dran
ich mach da gar nix mehr
ok Leute ich glaube
ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
jetzt so gut
weil das Ding nicht geladen ist
IP passt immer noch
alles gut
oh macht der jetzt was
jetzt updatet er
easy einfach nochmal ausführen
er blinkt
er blinkt wie verrückt
1,79 its pro Sekunde
ja komm bei den Chinesen
kannst du es nicht so genau nehmen
sag mal hat Schalke ein eSport Team
ich glaube schon
die haben irgendein FIFA Team
FIFA und
Street Fighter oder sowas
irgendwie so Zeug
was eigentlich kaum einen interessiert
ich glaube die haben ein FIFA Team
LOL LOL nicht Street Fighter
LOL
was LOL
er spricht
was hat er gesagt?
Firmware aktualisiert
er blinkt wie verrückt rum
er blinkt wie verrückt
geht das Web Interface noch
ok das Web Interface geht noch
aber er blinkt immer noch
Settings
Info
Firmware Version
ok das ist noch die alte Version
Blog Surfer
China Cloud
ok ich glaube solange der blinkt
wird er noch intern updaten
danach geht es hoffe ich
und danach verbinden wir uns per SSH auf den Staubsauger
ich hoffe der behält die IP bei
sonst wüsste ich gar nicht
wüsste ich gar nicht
wie ich da jetzt noch dran komme an die Kiste
ok er blinkt immer noch
ich muss mal ein Ohr vom Headset raus machen
dass ich höre was er sagt
was sind das für Zeiten
PSSH auf den Memory Leak
den Staubsauger connecten
ja so ist das 2019
wir sind voll im Internet of Shits
wir blinken ja nur mal wenn der im gleichen WLAN drin ist
wenn das Ding sich jetzt nicht ordentlich
zum WLAN connectet
dann müsste ich wahrscheinlich per USB dran oder so
hoffen wir mal das Beste
kennst du den Twitter Account
Internet of Shits ja klar
please wait until vacuum reboots
er blinkt
immer noch ganz schnell gerade
übrigens meine 50 USB Kabel
aus China sind immer noch nicht angekommen
also die angeblich 250
USB Kabel
oh er ist weg
die Kabel sind
2 IZ pro Sekunde
ne 1,93 IZ pro Sekunde
er blinkt immer noch wie verrückt
ha da ist er wieder
da ist er wieder
ok Leute
ich hab kurz die Luft angehalten
gerade ehrlich gesagt
ich hab kurz die Luft
angehalten dass der nicht wieder
bootet
warum ist eigentlich das Emote noch nicht drin
white people happy
müsste eigentlich funktionieren
warum funktioniert das nicht
die Chatbox sollte eigentlich FFZ
können
kann die Chatbox kein FFZ
oh fail da brauchst du eine neue Chatbox
aber das ist jetzt
aber das ist jetzt das kleinste Problem was ich hab
was hat der denn für Schmerzen jetzt
der updatet
immer noch
der updatet immer noch
der blinkt immer noch wie verrückt rum
der irkst das wäre eine richtig gute Idee
nice
fuck
suck suck fuck fuck
warum ist deine Batterie denn jetzt auf einmal 100% voll
keine Ahnung musst du die Chinesen fragen
die das gebaut haben
irgendwie ok
ich warte einfach bis der fertig blinken ist
äh Zergo hast du den auch geflasht
gibt es dafür schon Custom Firmware für den S6
warum wird der Staubsauger gerootet
der Staubsauger wird gerootet
dass er keine China Cloud mehr braucht
und es gibt ja Leute
die sagen ja nicht China die sagen China
also die würden dann sagen dass der Staubsauger
China Cloud mal benötigt
und auch dass der
der setzt ja auch keine chemischen Reinigungsmittel
ein der Staubsauger
oh er ist wieder weg
er ist wieder weg
er macht Sounds
er hat Sounds gemacht
Lad er hat Lad gesagt
Staubsauger warum pingst du nicht mehr
erfolgreich aktualisiert
hat er gesagt
ha ok
ping ist wieder da
ich hab keinen Bock einen 300€
Staubsauger zu pricken irgendwie
ich glaub mein Browser hat es noch nicht
gecheckt irgendwie
warte mal ich mach mal ein neues
window off
loading state
der
spackt irgendwie übelst rum oder
info
ja der spackt
aber hier 0.4 hat er
gucken ob mal gucken
ob SSH geht
SSH äh Wut
60 107
yes
und wir sind per root auf unserem Staubsauger
äh PSSH
auf unserem Staubsauger
POG
easy clap
warum der allerdings die Oberfläche nicht richtig
lädt checke ich nicht
ich glaube aber irgendwie das liegt an meinem
ups
ich glaube irgendwie das liegt an meinem Browser
Browser
es liegt nicht an meinem Browser
was hat er was hat er für Schmerzen
nice und nu
naja nice ist es nicht er funktioniert ja nicht
was hast du für eine Tastatur
irgendeine Corsar
LED Premium Dings
ich weiß nicht wie das Ding genau heißt
ist das das gleiche
ist das das gleiche was ich eben schon
was ich eben auch verwendet hab
upload
ach Moment ich bin auf dem Staubsauger drauf
ups
ja ne 555
961 ja das ist
das ist das gleiche
ich reboote das Ding mal
das ist Custom Firmware drauf
das ist komplett
fertig jetzt eigentlich wenn es funktionieren würde
wir rebooten mal
wir rebooten das Ding einfach mal
ich meine es ist schon
nice das man seinen Staubsauger per SSH
rebooten kann
und wie heißt die Firma äh die Firmware
die Firma heißt ähm
Valle
Tuduo Github
POC
der rebootet jetzt und ist ganz schön lahm im rebooten
da ist er wieder
hoffentlich gehts jetzt
HA
oder
ja funktioniert
POC Reboot hilft
Reboot hilft
Reboot hilft immer
Map
die Map ist ziemlich kacke
so Leute wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen können
ich kann das Ding jetzt nehmen
mal ins Wohnzimmer stellen
und wir
werden den mal über das Web Interface
im Wohnzimmer aktivieren
und dann gucken wie er die Map aufbaut und alles
wollen wir das mal machen
muss ich einfach einen Raum weiter bringen jetzt
ok ich bin gleich wieder da
Twitch Plays
Roborock
Cleaning Apartment
ok ich habe ihn ins Wohnzimmer gesteckt
ähm
äh ins Wohnzimmer gestellt
die Ladestation ist noch hier
ok gucken wir mal
Map
Map ist
Map ist immer noch das alte Zimmer ok
schau mal Start
Start
ja hey er baut das Wohnzimmer auf
POC
oder auch nicht doch jetzt
er regent das Wohnzimmer
ja habe ich Ricky
allerdings gibt es jetzt eine neue Firma Version die viel besser ist
Wohnzimmer League
das ist halt super nice
jetzt fehlt bloß noch ein Raspberry mit einer Kamera drauf oder
ich habe jetzt nichts hochgestellt im Wohnzimmer
das ist ziemlich ziemlich kompliziert
für den jetzt
hier steht ein Tisch das sieht man ja hier ist die Eingangstür
hier steht hier steht Sofa
ein Sessel steht hier in der Ecke
hier steht ein Tisch hier vorne steht der Fernseher
hier liegt ein Katzentunnel rum
also der kann jetzt hier nicht sonderlich gerade fahren aber gucken wir mal was er macht
gucken wir mal was er macht
was kann die neue Version ja das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich an
also wir probieren jetzt ein paar neue Versionen aus
die Katze die liegt unten auf dem Schrank glaube ich
die ist nicht im Wohnzimmer
ich glaube das hier sind die Tisch und Stuhlbeine
die er da gerade umfährt
they see me rolling
genau das ist ohne Scheiß
das wissen wir jetzt echt
das passt jetzt echt gut dazu
guck mal das scannt jetzt auch unterm Sofahr
genug gerollt
aber das schöne ist man sieht
man sieht sogar auf der Map worauf er schon lange gefahren ist
oh jetzt ist er unterm Sofahr
jetzt ist er unterm Sofahr
gucken ob er da raus kommt
ist nämlich nicht so einfach da hinten kommt er nicht so einfach
einfach raus.
Okay, anscheinend doch.
Da steht nämlich noch was davor.
Aber wahrscheinlich passt er unten drunter durch.
Twitch Plays
Staubsaugerroboter.
Okay, jetzt können wir mal die neuen Features ausprobieren.
Zonen.
Ich habe schon ein paar Zonen angelegt.
Allerdings noch nach dem alten Muster.
Wir legen jetzt mal eine neue Zone an.
Nehmen wir mal
Test
Add
Weil man
kann jetzt auf der Map
kann man jetzt direkt sagen, hier
ich möchte Zone anlegen.
So, keine Ahnung.
Zone
Teppich oder so.
Teppich müsste hier so sein.
Zone Teppich.
Ach hier.
Teppich.
Safe.
So, und wo kann man das No-Go-Areas
machen?
Das haben die ja geschrieben.
Man kann dem jetzt sagen, wo er nicht
hinfahren soll.
Wie macht man No-Go-Areas?
Verbinden. Ah, okay.
Ach hier.
Okay, verbinden.
Ich will nicht, dass du...
Ah, das ist eine Wand.
Wow.
Okay.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken, ob da drüben auch noch
wirklich was treibt.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt hier wieder...
Okay, naja.
Das will ich nicht.
Kann man das nicht?
Kann man das nicht das Messer irgendwie...
Verbinden Zones.
So, das ist eine virtuelle Wand.
Und das hier ist wahrscheinlich
ein No-Go-Area.
So, No-Go-Area.
No-Go-Area.
Da.
Ich will das ja einfach nochmal ausbilden.
So, und virtuelle Wand?
Da.
Safe.
Okay, das geht anscheinend nur global.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder auch nicht?
Wie löscht man den Shit wieder hier?
Rot, ne?
Okay, ich will nicht, dass du hierhin
goest.
thing.
Dahin.
ist go und verboten.
Ah, man muss das erstmal bestätigen mit grün.
Jetzt sagt man, okay.
Nö. Irgendwie ist das kaputt.
Funktioniert nicht.
Vielleicht kann man das auch nicht machen.
Vielleicht kann man das auch nicht machen,
während der fährt.
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Gucken wir mal zu, wie er fährt.
Ah, siehste?
Macht schön ordentlich sauber.
Schön ordentlich sauber macht er.
Oh, es gibt Subs.
Hab ich bestimmt wieder übersehen.
Wen haben wir denn?
Nako Libre.
Nacho Libre.
Prime Sub.
Nice.
Gibt es das Webinterface nur,
wenn man Custom-Firmware drauf hat?
Ja.
Die offizielle Firmware hat gar kein Webinterface.
Und auch kein SSH oder sowas.
Sondern einfach nur eine App,
die man
entweder
iOS verwenden kann.
Und die hat mittlerweile auch,
ich würde mal fast sagen,
funktionsmäßig ist die Custom-Firmware
mittlerweile sogar besser.
Als die offizielle.
Ich sehe auch schon eine andere Verbesserung.
Der hatte,
am Anfang hatte der ein bisschen Probleme,
was den Fernseher angeht.
Der Fernseher hat seine Laser
Laser
Strahlen, die er zum Raumscannen
verwendet,
hat der
Fernseher reflektiert.
Das hat dazu geführt,
dass der Raum immer größer geworden ist.
Jedes Mal, wenn er auf- und abgefahren ist.
Das war natürlich ziemlich Fail.
Und das ist jetzt nicht mehr so.
Das heißt, er hat unendlich lange das Wohnzimmer geputzt,
wenn du Pech hattest.
Das ist jetzt nicht so.
Der erkennt jetzt auch Außenwände hier richtig.
Die macht er so blau.
Das ist gut.
Das hat er vorher auch nicht gemacht.
Letztes Firmware.
Also das Firmware-Update scheint sich schon mal gelohnt zu haben.
Ich schalte jetzt meine Client-Isolation
wieder an fürs WLAN.
Ich hoffe, der fährt weiter,
auch wenn er WLAN-Verbindung verliert.
Mal gucken, was er macht,
wenn er WLAN-Verbindung verliert.
So, jetzt sollte er gleich WLAN-Verbindung
oder wir sollten auch gleich WLAN-Verbindung
verlieren.
Ja, jetzt haben wir WLAN-Verbindung verloren.
Sollte allerdings
sich gleich wieder erledigt haben
und wieder funktionieren.
Na gut, den Ping können wir uns...
Ups, ich habe die komplette...
Ich habe die komplette...
Es ist das Hase schon abgeschossen.
Funktioniert wieder, okay.
Map.
Ja.
Der umrundet ja den Tisch ein bisschen, ne?
Aber ihr habt gesehen, wie schnell der sauber macht, ne?
Dadurch, dass der das Ganze scannen kann,
ist der ziemlich, ziemlich zackig.
Und was man hier auch noch einstellen kann,
ist Carpet-Mode,
also für den Teppich.
Da kann man einstellen, wie stark er mehr
sackt,
wenn er über den Teppich fährt.
Haha, na,
Nacolique...
Nacho-Libre?
Na, Nacho-Libre?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man es genannt hat,
aber das ist ein gutes Comment.
2019...
Also Vorstellung von 2019, 1960.
Menschheit kolonialisiert den Mars.
Realität 2019.
Staubsauger mit SSH.
So, jetzt macht er noch schön
unter dem Sofa sauber.
Und dann hoffentlich ohne, ohne
zu stacken.
Aber macht er auch wirklich sauber
oder gehst du danach nochmal,
oder gehst du danach, ist sauber.
Also, er ersetzt nicht, dass du
ab und zu mal mit dem richtigen
Staubsauger staubsaugen musst.
Also so komplett alle Ecken, 100 pro
ist nicht, aber du musst viel, viel
weniger Staubsaugen. Also wenn du sonst,
wenn du wolltest, dass es halbwegs ordentlich ist,
musstest du so alle, alle zwei Wochen oder so
mal staubsaugen.
Und mit dem Ding kannst du jetzt, theoretisch,
wenn du es übertragst, saugst du im halben Jahr
musst du einmal staubsaugen.
Du kannst es aber einfach sein lassen.
Also, der macht dort, wo er
langfährt, macht das schon gut, sauber.
Hasenkürze, nutzt ihr agile Methoden
auf der Arbeit? Wenn ja, welche? Also,
ansonsten, also an sich sind wir nicht der
aller agilste Laden, was das anbelangt.
Ähm, wir haben
bloß ein paar Projekte und auch nur
die neueren Sachen, die sind
furchtbar agile. Und
wir haben das, was wahrscheinlich die meisten
haben. Wir haben ein Jira mit
Kanban-Board und Geschiss.
Und das war's
zum größten Teil. Kaufst du dir
auch noch einen routbaren Wischroboter?
Dazu, damit er, ähm,
der kann wischen.
Cheat, 195. Der hat
ein Fach für, für, ähm,
der hat einen Lappen, den du unten per
Klettverschluss
dran machen kannst und er hat ein Fach für Wasser.
Habe ich aber noch nie
verwendet. Guck mal,
gibt sogar ein Video zu.
Ja, da wird gewischt.
Monka Mob.
Die Katz den Staubsauger, oh, die hat Schiss vor dem
Staubsauger.
Der extreme Wischstück.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen Zeitraffer.
Uuh.
Ja, zeigt mal, zeigt mal, wie er wischt.
Bruder muss groß.
Bruder muss groß war
das hier eher. Nicht Bruder muss
groß. Das sieht doch ganz
okay aus.
Ja, okay, ist halt.
Dachte ich mir.
Deswegen verwende ich die Wischfunktion auch nicht.
Vielleicht geht er aber auch
mehrfach drüber und sieht danach gut aus.
Aber ganz im Ernst, das Ding hat
einen Mini-Wassertank und
einen recht kleinen Lappen.
Kann euch das mal zeigen, ob es ein Bild.
Genau das ist der Lappen, den machst du da per
per Klettverschluss dran.
Und hier hinten.
Genau hier hinten, das ist, das ist glaube ich
der Staubtank und da gibt's
noch einen ganz kleinen Wassertank.
Ja.
Sowas hier, das kann
nicht wahnsinnig gut sein.
Das ist der Staubtank.
Ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, ob der noch mal drüber geht.
Guck, das ist, das ist ein bisschen schwer.
Das ist die offizielle App, Leute.
Da ist doch, da ist doch hier.
So, guck mal, er ist wieder angedockt.
Siehste?
Einmal schön durchs Wohnzimmer gefahren,
sauber gemacht, den Teppich besonders
sauber gemacht, wieder an die Dockingstation.
Huge.
Warum möchtest du den routen?
Ja, zum Beispiel lasse ich dieses Webinterface hier ab.
Das Problem an der offiziellen App ist,
beziehungsweise an der offiziellen,
an der offiziellen Firmware,
du musst die offizielle App verwenden
und die offizielle App, die muss man nicht verwenden.
Geht immer über die Cloud in China.
Immer.
Das heißt, wenn die China-Cloud mal nicht da ist,
kannst du deine Wohnung nicht sauber machen.
Und außerdem will ich auch nicht meinen Grundriss
vom Haus irgendwie nach China übertragen
oder ein Gerät, was die ganze Zeit Connection
in die China-Cloud hat.
Wozu?
Außerdem hat man mit der Custom-Firmware
auch viele Funktionen,
die es so gar nicht gibt in der offiziellen Firmware.
Zum Beispiel ein Webinterface
und SSH-Zugang.
Ich meine, wer hat schon,
wer hat schon einen Staubsauger-Roboter
mit SSH-Zugang?
Wer hat schon einen Staubsauger-Roboter
Ach, der Key ist ja falsch.
Da können wir gleich mal
die Key-Upload-Funktion testen.
Äh...
Info?
Wo ist das mit den SSH-Keys?
Ah, hier.
Access-Key.
Key-Settings.
Nehmen wir mal den da.
Ah, lustig.
Ich habe noch hier den SSH-Key vom letzten Mal
flaschen rumliegen.
Kann man da auch?
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Da kann man mehrere reinmachen.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Kann man da mehrere reinmachen?
Also ich meine, ja, man kann mehrere reinmachen,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob es da noch funktioniert.
SSH-Keys-Settings.
Die Mehrzahl.
Probieren wir es einfach mal aus.
Save.
Das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Das wäre ja easy as a fuck gewesen.
Und da sind wir drauf per SSH.
Übrigens ist ein Ubuntu drauf.
Äh, sorry, ein Ubuntu
ist da drauf.
Und zwar ein ziemlich altes, ein 1404.
1404 LTS
ist auf dem Staubsauger drauf.
Man kann übrigens,
jetzt nur mal, dass ich es gesagt habe,
man könnte hier auch
zum Beispiel
ähm
man könnte auch Web-Server drauf installieren.
Ne, kann man nicht.
Apt, Install.
Das kann man hier installieren. Alles mögliche.
Also alles, was irgendwie da ist.
Search.
Wim.
Wim installieren auf einem
Wim installieren auf einem Staubsauger
zum Beispiel.
Oder kann man
das ASCII, ASCII-Quarium
vielleicht. Ne.
ASCII-Quarium gibt es nicht.
Also man kann quasi
alles mögliche
installieren, was es für Ubuntu 1404
gibt.
Kann man, könnte man
einen Desktop installieren?
Ne, haha, das wäre es ja.
Irgendwie
keine Ahnung, ein XXLXDE
oder sowas auf dem
Staubsauger-Roboter.
Wo hostest du deine Homepage
auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter?
Gnome.
Ne, ist
nicht dabei.
Mach mal Dist-Upgrade, danach ist es den Grip.
Arbeitest du mit
Node und Babel?
Normalerweise nicht.
Also ich weiß beides, was es ist. Ich kann beides
verwenden.
Aber
wenn ich es mir aussuchen kann, nicht.
Wie gesagt,
mein Lieblings-Backend-Umgebung ist
nach wie vor .NET
beziehungsweise .NET Core.
Und wenn es
Node.js sein muss, nehme ich auch Node.js.
Wenn ich neuere
Script-Features brauche, dann kann ich
auch Babel nehmen, aber
selten.
Ich finde das toll, dass das so einfach funktioniert.
Ich will jetzt zunächst mal Htop drauf.
Gibt es nicht.
Aber Top gibt es, oder?
Export Term
gleich Xterm.
Wahrscheinlich buggt das rum. Ja, Top ist drauf.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich
ein Update mache?
Oh, stimmt! Wow.
Stimmt, kann ich Docker installieren.
Docker
LXD, LXC, LXD
Ne.
Update.
Connecting, US-Ports, Ubuntu.
Nein, geht nicht.
ARM-CPU, gute Frage,
was das für eine CPU ist.
Ja.
Moment, ich glaube, das Ding spackt
gerade nicht. Guck mal, was das für eine CPU ist.
Hast du eine Anleitung zum Routen irgendwo?
Ja, hier auf der offiziellen Webseite von denen.
Na.
Gehst du einfach hin auf GitHub
valetudo
und nimmst hier den Installation Guide.
Das haben wir auch gerade gemacht.
Nacho Libre
für unter Linux
kann ich dir nur Rider empfehlen.
Wir haben hier
mein Twitch
Chat-Mitschneide-Programm.
Also das da.
Ne, das da.
Was quasi Fragen,
die an mich gestellt werden, mitloggt.
Das ist komplett
unter Linux in Rider entstanden.
Das ist echt nice gewesen.
Ich mache es auch lieber unter Windows und Visual Studio.
Ja, muss ich auch sagen.
Wir wollten gucken, was da für eine
CPU drin ist.
Nicht ETC.
Da ist drin ein
ARM-V7 mit so gut wie
keinen Features.
Allerdings, sehe ich das richtig,
ein 4-Kern-ARM-Prozessor ist im
Staubsauger drin.
EACS, das Problem ist,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man
einfach Pakete und Sounds reinkriegt.
Ist das richtig?
Das ist ein 4-Kern-CPU
im Staubsauger?
Stimmt, wie viel RAM hat das Ding?
512.
Was ist das für komische Musik?
Die Ubuntu-Repos sind drin.
Ach, ich weiß, warum ich nichts
installieren kann.
Ich kann nichts installieren, weil das Ding
in meinem China-WLAN hängt.
Das China-WLAN hat ja keinen Zugriff nach außen.
Und das ist auch gut so.
Wie könnte ich denn jetzt auslesen?
Was sagt DF?
DF sagt,
es gibt so gut wie keinen Speicherplatz drauf.
512. Guckt mal, Leute.
512 MB Speicher
und, ach ne,
wartet mal.
Ne.
2 GB Flash ist da drin.
2G.
2G Flash. Kommt ungefähr hin.
1,64. Ungefähr 2 GB.
2 GB und
512 MB RAM.
IP-Tables.
Kann man mal gucken.
IP-Tables minus V minus L.
Ich kann mir immer IP-Tables nicht merken.
Ah, hier. Reject.
Reject. Alles, was zur China-Cloud
geht, wird gedroppt.
Alles, was zur China-Cloud geht, wird gedroppt.
Ach, ne. Moment.
Das ist Update. Update-Url.
Update für Firmware-Updates wird gedroppt.
Da ist nicht so viel drin.
Ich geb den jetzt aber auch nicht frei,
dass wir irgendeinen Mist installieren können
auf dem...
auf dem Staubsauger, weil, wie gesagt,
ich will ihn nicht kaputt machen.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn ich es irgendwie hinkriege,
dass das Root-File-System voll ist,
dann hat das Ding wahrscheinlich echt Probleme.
Das riskieren wir jetzt mal nicht.
Aber nice. Nice.
Wir haben eine neue Firmware-Version drauf.
Wir haben einmal
ein Wohnzimmer sauber gemacht.
Was ich gut finde, ist, dass er
die alten Zonen behalten hat.
Das ist sehr nice.
Manual Control.
Sieht immer noch so hässlich aus wie vorher.
Das kann man nur gut mit einem Tablet steuern.
Das ist so ein Mini-Joystick, soll das quasi sein.
Ja, nice.
Nice.
Warum klickst du immer auf Kopieren?
Kann ich dir beantworten. Ganz einfach.
Ausrufezeichen 1.
Gibt's extra schon einen FAQ-Eintrag für.
Warum hat der vorher eigentlich gelabert,
von wegen Batterie nicht 20% geladen?
Der ist bei 91%.
Sehr laut.
Modus aktiviert.
Könnte man hier an das Projekt
an das Projekt donaten.
An Paypal der Hüpfer.
War easy.
80 Millionen.
Ne. 8 Millionen.
Was ist das Maximale, was man überweisen
kann bei Paypal?
10 Millionen. Okay.
Easy.
Money.
Balanced. Quiet. Ach ja. Stimmt.
Ich hab vorhin gefragt, hat jemand wie die Lautstärke ist
von dem Ding.
Also auf dem Standard-Settings ist es in Ordnung.
Wo es halt ordentlich
laut wird ist, wenn der
feststellt, dass er auf einem
Teppich ist. Das kann man hier nämlich
einschalten. Und wenn er auf dem Teppich
ist, dreht er halt voll hoch.
Das ist aber auch okay, dann wird der Teppich ordentlich sauber.
Nice.
Leute, eins muss man sagen, heute haben wir
ziemlich Progress gemacht, oder?
Kaum Sidetrack so.
Und in 2 Stunden
haben wir das Ding geflasht mit einer neuen Version
und funktioniert.
Pock.
Kann ich den Raspberry mal wieder ausschalten?
Achso, ja.
Damn.
Ich find's aber echt
toll, dass man per SSH
auf seinen Staubsauger connecten kann.
Das ist einfach so Next Level Shit.
In Ordnung?
Ich muss mal
unterschiedliche Sounds
für Subs und Follows machen.
Ich muss mal unterschiedliche Sounds
Ähm,
wo geht denn das?
Das probier ich also mal kurz aus.
Ähm, Test Follow.
Okay, das macht der Sound.
Test Subscription macht den Sound.
Außer, dass er ein bisschen lauter ist,
ist überhaupt kein Unterschied.
ähm
wir brauchen einen neuen Subscribersound
Sounds, was haben wir da zu bieten für Sounds
kann man irgendwie die Vorschau ordentlich machen
ich kann die Sounds nicht hören richtig
das müssten wir als
das müssten wir als Sub-Sound haben
ok, Select
jetzt haben wir einen anderen Sound
mal gucken, was das für ein Sound das ist
ne, das ist nix
das ist Kack-Sound dafür
wo kam das jetzt her
Daniel Lull, Tier 1, dankeschön
das hat mich jetzt voll verwirrt
ähm, Homeworld, also generell ist es schwierig dem Roboter Sounds beizubringen
es gibt ein fertiges deutsches Voice-Pack
wie man das editiert habe ich keine Ahnung
ok
was könnten wir für Sounds, was könnte man für Sounds nehmen
was ist ein guter Sound für Subscription
wir bräuchten diesen Windows-Anmeldesound von früher
ne, das war der Abmeldesound
ok, das ist schonmal besser, das kann ich wenigstens unterscheiden
dann ist das hier Follow
und das hier ist Sub
klingt zwar immer noch nicht gut
aber wir müssen uns was anderes noch ausdenken
aber ich kann es zumindest schonmal am Sound unterscheiden
ich muss mir das nachher mal anhören, was es für unterschiedliche Sounds gibt
ich muss mir das nachher mal anhören, was für unterschiedliche Sounds gibt
so Leute
eigentlich sind wir fertig, ne
eigentlich sind wir fertig
geroutet
Mode im Connect-Sound
ich muss mir nachher mal Gedanken machen
außerdem brauche ich noch, übrigens falls jemand, irgendjemand kennt
der gut ist im Emotes und Sub-Badges und sowas Design
sagt mir mal bitte Bescheid
das ist auch nicht umsonst
also für mich muss keiner umsonst irgendwelche Dinger entwerfen
Max bau eine Wasserkühlung in Staubsauger
ja genau
natürlich
wie kann man jetzt eigentlich gucken wie viel Taktfrequenz die CPU hat?
bist du Max FPS auf YouTube?
ja das bin ich
Moment, man muss dafür irgendwelche C Sachen programmieren um die Taktfrequenz rauszukriegen?
Aha
das da können wir auch machen
Max CPU Frequency
dann machen wir einfach CUR
CUR
Ja, Diablo 2 wird drauf laufen wahrscheinlich.
Hast du deine Dot-Files auf GitHub?
Ne, hab ich gar nichts von da.
Nope.
Könnte ich aber mal machen.
Der USB-Disconnect-Sound.
Oh, das ist fies.
Das ist fies.
Genauso, was auch fies ist, ist dieses Ding hier.
Streamer-Knock-Sound.
Prank-Sound.
Ja, das ist fies, das Ding.
Das ist fies, oder?
Das hört sich echt an.
Das hört sich echt an, als ist es gerade einer an der Tür.
Kopfhörer-User werden krass geprankt, ja.
Erstmal Yogi sein, ja klar.
Das ist der übelste Prank.
Wie bestimmt man soll Subscriber sagen?
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Wartet mal, wie hört sich Subscriber hier an?
Subscriber.
Ne, oder?
Max, was hast du überlegt für Sub-Badges?
Was?
Ich habe noch keine großartige Ahnung, deswegen wäre es nice, wenn ich jemand hätte, der da skillmäßig in der Lage ist, was zu zeichnen oder überhaupt halt was zu designen und man sich mit dem zusammen was überlegen könnte.
Weil am besten ist immer, man hat eine grobe Idee, hat dann jemand, der das machen kann und überlegt sich dann zusammen, was rauskommt am Ende.
Sub-Badge muss ein Keks werden.
Ja, aber mein Keks.
Der Keks an sich ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen groß für die Sub-Badge.
Oder?
Die soll die Namen von den Subs vorlesen.
Das müssen wir aber erst noch programmieren.
Das lasse ich lieber den Nightbot machen oder den Streamlabs machen, die können das bestimmt nämlich.
Ne, der Vogel nicht, das muss irgendein Keks sein.
Ein bisschen was, ein bisschen Bezug zu YouTube sollte das schon haben.
Aber ich finde das eigentlich gar nicht so blöd hier.
Ja.
Das ist besser.
Das ist viel besser.
Oder?
Ich find's besser als das erste.
Das einzige Problem, was ich hab, ist, dass ich irgendwie mein Tool kaputt gemacht hab,
dass wenn ich jetzt hier…
Ach, jetzt funktioniert's.
Nice.
Alles gut, funktioniert.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht Polybar.
Das ist, ähm, wo war denn die Frage?
Welche Shell-Terminal-Status-Bar benutzt du?
Ähm, das ist, äh, also wie gesagt, die Distribution ist Majaro mit, ähm, i3 als, als Desktop.
Das ist ein Gnome-Terminal.
Das ist ZSH.
Und das hier oben ist, ähm, nennt sich i3-Status-Rust.
Das da.
Da brauchst du noch einen passenden Image-Font.
Und dann hast du das dann so, so schick.
Wird der Staubsauger gerade übertaktet?
Ne, der Staubsauger ist fertig.
Eigentlich sind wir fertig.
Ich glaube, ich könnte jetzt was futtern.
Hast du noch deinen alten Server-Raum?
Ja, den habe ich noch.
Ähm, okay.
Also.
Warte ich mal.
Wen, wen haben wir denn da?
Ob es, ne, ich will mich nicht selbst angucken.
Wen haben wir noch in Science & Technology, den man hosten könnte?
Ist wieder keiner da, oder was?
Nope.
Der ist aber echt hartnäckig.
Der war das letzte Mal schon da, ja.
Der ist immer stundenlang am Java, am Java-Zeug streamen.
Ich meine, wenn es ja nicht Java wäre, ne.
Ist doch erst 19 Uhr.
Ja, vielleicht.
Vielleicht.
Aber das ist jetzt, es ist wirklich nur, nur ganz vielleicht.
Komme ich nachher nochmal on.
Aber ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Social Eating, ja.
Ähm.
Warum sind das Kanäle auf Deutsch, nachdem ich gerade Deutsch als Filter entfernt habe?
Twitch, was ist das für eine Logik?
Okay, das ist, was ist das?
Polnisch.
Polnisch heißt es PC zusammenbauen.
Epic Linux Game Development.
Wusste ich das, Epic Linux Game Development?
Er sieht nicht glücklich aus, oder?
Er sieht echt nicht glücklich aus, mit der ganzen Sache.
Er sieht leicht, leicht leidend aus, irgendwie.
Coding von Netflix.
Oh, C++, das ist die Hardcore-Variante.
Alter, Leute, C++ ist so hässlich, guckt euch das mal an.
Igitt, das sieht so, das sieht, ach Gott, es ist C++.
Ich gucke mal auf dem anderen Rechner, ob es irgendjemand gibt, in dem ich followe.
Du folgst.
Wie heißt nochmal die API, die du für das Anime, für die Anime-Grill-Voice, ähm, verwendest?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, das war irgendein japanischer Text-to-Speech-Service.
Könnt mal gucken, wie das Ding hieß, ähm, wie hieß das denn?
Wenn ich mich in meinem Source-Code noch zurecht...
Ah ja, Text-to-Speech-Service.
Das habe ich ja sogar mal sinnvoll benannt.
Sachen gibt's.
POC.
Ähm, ja.
API-Voice-Text.
Und dann kannst du hier hinter angeben, wie du willst, dass das, also welche, welchen Sprecher du haben willst,
wie die drauf sein soll und, und das Emotion-Level.
Also wir haben das auf Happy, auf extrem Happy eingestellt.
Das Emotion-Level.
Was?
Wo, wo benutze ich das denn?
Habe ich doch überhaupt nicht.
Oder meinst du den, oder meinst du den C++-Dude auf, auf Twitch gerade?
Der C++-Typer.
Ja.
Ja, also, API-Voice-Text.
Full-Stack.
React.
Golang.
DynamoDB.
Lambda.
Living in a wheelchair.
Was es alles für, für Streams gibt mittlerweile.
Final Fantasy UI TypeScript.
Purple...
Was für Zeugs, ey.
Was ist DynamoDB?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine hippe NoSQL-Datenbank.
Okay.
Jetzt, wo ich lese, fällt's mir wieder ein.
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Das ist, wie ich gesagt habe, eine hippe NoSQL-Datenbank.
Ja, da ist irgendwie nix dabei, was mir gefällt zum Hosten oder was wir nicht schon gehostet
haben.
Okay, Leute, machen wir Schluss
Vielleicht, aber ich, wie gesagt, würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen
Bin ich nachher nochmal am Start
Aber Staubsauger hosten hat echt gut funktioniert
Diesmal
Hast du schon mal Hive oder Hadoop in Production verwendet?
Nein, hab ich nicht
Hab ich nicht
Ähm
Ja
Leute, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal
Die Fragen beantworte ich das nächste Mal
Hört mir grad auf
So ganz schön viel Zeug drin
Bis dann